hey I love the sweater he's slaying a
knight Ladykiller well we shall see what
we shall see
no you're dressed exactly like the lady
killer damn it
she's Jeffrey Dahmer's corduroys all
over again alright let's get started
Scully where are you on digitizing the
old Case Files as of yesterday I'm
officially 1% done why are you smiling
that's nothing
boy there's thousands of cases and for
each one I have to fill out 200 little
box thingies on 50 different screens
least you get to sit on your butt all
day that's actually the worst part my
doctor said I have an anal Canyon Scully
why are you always telling us about your
disgusting body I don't see anything
that's because it's all bored
[Applause]
how are you married
Peralta where are we on the Adam Street
burglary we are very close captain aside
from a complete absence of evidence
suspects or leads so in conclusion not
at all close and the vicar Street
aggravated assault stalled out and the
Calloway robbery also remains unsolved
due to a lack of solving it by me sounds
like someone's in a little bit of a
slump I'm not in a slump you're not
scoreboard
I don't slump people I opposite slump i
p-muls that slump backwards and it's
what i do i p-muls all over this [ __ ]
dismissed
slump people's wait before you say
anything I want to guess what happened
based on your face someone died
no you want a prize I'm not getting
better at this I'm concerned that the
open cases mound of garbage on your desk
has become so much higher than the
closed cases mound of garbage all right
sir let me get you with a little analogy
are you familiar with racecars Formula
one or stock that's already way more
than I know about it the point is I'm a
super awesome race car whose hit a
couple of unlucky speed bumps you're a
speed bumps on the racetrack is that not
part of car racing it should be all I'm
saying is it's open road again I'm about
to close the case missing grandma Helen
storino last Sunday her grandson Judd
reported she went out for bagels and
ever came back this morning we picked up
an old lady matching her description
exactly
I showed her pictures of Judd and she
said and I quote what did I say about
doing voices I'm a storyteller sir
it's my craft anyways grandsons coming
in they reunite and I throw another case
on the old salted pile hey my croissant
ah mr. mrs. Torino I'm glad you're here
may I present to you oh my darlings
thank God I found you oh look at those
beautiful cheeks I have no idea who this
lady is I've never seen her before in my
life
what no she recognized you this is Helen
Helen I'm not really her husband she's
so much shorter than you used to be what
did the Japanese do do different
generation okay this is Ethel mustard
Berg from the Prospect Heights Senior
Center
there was an ID card in her back pocket
why was your hand in her back pocket
well she told me she didn't have any ID
and I'm like Boyle my first instinct was
not to caress her but frisked i frisked
her but it looks like this case remains
unsolved Peralta
oh my god
you